the idea that a family like my family in
Argentina could have something to
protect themselves from the government
is incredibly attractive hi I'm Zack why
smaller for recent TV here with
Wednesday's kisara its founder of zap oh
and online bitcoin wallet my sis thank
you very much for talking to us thank
you for having music you are originally
from Argentina you actually brought the
first Internet service provider there
and he founded the financial services
company in a pentagon what actually
brought you from more traditional online
services to the Wild West of Bitcoin
when I saw Bitcoin for the first time I
thought it was the most revolutionary
thing I've seen in my career together
with the Internet I felt like we have
done collectively as an industry a very
poor job at really improving finance if
you think about what the average
checking account looks like today and
debit cards and credit cards and ATMs
it's pretty much the same as 30 years
ago and pretty much the same percentage
of world population has access to those
services which is a very small
percentage and I was losing hope that
technology was gonna change that until I
saw Bitcoin and I said oh my god this is
changes everything he may do for money
what the internet did for information
did your experience growing up in
Argentina inform your understanding of
Bitcoin at all definitely yeah I mean I
grew up in Patagonia in the southern
part of Argentina and while growing up I
saw my parents lose everything three
times for very different reasons but
always related to Argentine economy and
the currency sometimes it was because of
hyperinflation and that I'm because of
it a huge devaluation another time
because the country confiscated bank
deposits so do you see Bitcoin as an
antidote to national currencies that can
just be endlessly inflated people make
bit more complicated than it is and the
three things that matter in Bitcoin are
one that nobody controls it no no person
or group of people no company no country
controls that's crucial and it would not
be interesting without that key feature
easy to say that is not very easy to
design a system that
works that way and Bitcoin has been
designed that way second is that there
will never be more than 21 million
bitcoins and nobody can change that if
that wasn't the case I wouldn't be
interested
being arts in pain number three is that
if you own any bitcoins you can send
them to anyone you want
anywhere in the world without asking
anyone's permission those three things
make it by far the best form of currency
we've ever seen the latest issue that's
been plaguing Bitcoin is this idea of a
hard fork in the blockchain where any
time there's some sort of update in the
core technology some people don't update
fast enough and there's two versions of
the blockchain running and they
eventually have to be consolidated based
on what a majority think is the correct
version the worry now is that people are
saying the blocks are too small to
process payments quickly enough and that
this is gonna turn into an unresolvable
situation where we forever have multiple
versions of the blockchain are you
concerned about this I am NOT concerned
the point of being concerned about
Bitcoin I think it's a very important
issue I think it's important at two
levels one level it's important to
increase the block size in my opinion
for bitcoins color scalability I don't
think it's a good idea to restrict the
number of transactions a Bitcoin can do
I think we want to enable as many
transactions as possible
and for that you have to do a fork but I
think that that's one discussion and
another discussion that is perhaps more
important is how do we go about doing
this right and the other thing they are
that discussion is more important and
there are right ways of doing it and
there are wrong ways of doing it and I
think the industry is trying to find the
right way of doing it in the process
creating some noise that makes people
concern there's this idea that decisions
are made regarding Bitcoin in a
decentralized manner that it's based on
consensus make you've called it the
fatherless technology when we have these
issues arising like blockchain size and
hard forks does Bitcoin need a father to
weigh in times time
authoritative I don't think so and I
think that Satoshi disappeared for a
reason I mean we don't know so I'm
speculating but I think Bitcoin is much
more robust because right now we cannot
depend on Satoshi to say hey Satoshi
what do we do with a block size right I
think that would be a weaker Bitcoin and
I think that probably couldn't happen
even if you were to re-emerge right he
gave up paternity the baby is not kids
anymore and I think that's important as
I said that's the number one key thing
Arabic and nobody controls it and it
makes some things very painful but it
wouldn't be interesting without that
feature with that pain that comes every
once in a while and you have these black
swans that nobody can predict why should
people trust it why should people put
their money into Bitcoin and and Trust
as a store value I think that for a few
years many years nobody should own an
amount of Bitcoin they cannot afford to
lose because bitcoin will remain
incredibly volatile and because there is
a non-trivial chance that Bitcoin lose
all its value right so it would be
imprudent and I responsible to recommend
to anyone that they have an amount of
Bitcoin that matters to them that they
cannot afford to lose so so as a store
of value I wouldn't tell people to keep
it as a store of value today because
it's very early it's an experiment and
there is still a chance that it could
fail and call it 20% right chance I also
happen to believe that there's a higher
than 50% chance that succeeds and if it
succeeds I happen to believe that a
Bitcoin will be more than will be worth
more than a million dollars so that's
four thousand times from what it is
today
two hundred and something so it it's
worth having something very little you
know 1% of your savings in Bitcoin makes
a lot of sense but you believe that it
will be useful as a store I think it
will replace gold as a as a main
interest international currency that
gold was for five thousand years yes it
will take years to get there and when it
does you'll probably be less volatile
than Bitcoin is today but probably just
as volatile as gold is today and gold is
quite volatile
libertarians tend to gravitate towards
Bitcoin because it undermines certain
aspects that the state allows them to
buy things that the state doesn't want
them to buy it allows them to just use a
non-governmental version of money what
do you think of the anti-government case
for Bitcoin and does all the libertarian
enthusiasm for it help it or does it
drive the non libertarians away from
Bitcoin and their mining government is
not what attracted me to Bitcoin but
definitely for example if the idea that
a family like my family in Argentina
could have something to protect
themselves from the government is
incredibly attractive to me so if the
government begins to take advantage of
them again and now they have something
that they can do against that and they
are not forced to keep pesos if they
don't want to there are many other
cryptocurrencies but no other one has
half a million people who believe in it
no matter what and a good core of that
is the libertarian group so I think that
in doing so they help Bitcoin
significantly you could argue that that
strong libertarian bent or association
with your talents has heard it a lot
with regulators and with bankers and I
think that that's true but net-net given
how much the core group of people of
that core group of people how many of
the very early authors were Italian and
how much having that very core group of
supporters helps it I think that net-net
were better off because of the
libertarians what is the oppo and what
does it do suppose a Bitcoin wallet and
fascinated with Bitcoin and I think that
the world would be a better place if
Bitcoin succeeded I wanna dedicate the
rest of my career to help it can succeed
and I won't support to be my instrument
to do that so we look at the biggest
hurdles that people have to get into
Bitcoin and and work on them today we
feel like the biggest hurdles are a lot
of people have concerns around security
you know if I get bitcoins how do i what
do I do with the private key how do I
secure myself on how to make sure I
won't lose it or my laptop or my
understanding is that Zapotec goes to
great lengths to physically secure the
servers where the Bitcoin are stored
there are underground across the world
there's biometric locks why do you go to
such great lengths to physically secure
your servers because I we believe that
no matter how good your
security team thinking that something is
unhackable would be our Logan everything
in theory is potentially hackable so the
best way to safe keep something that you
don't want to be hacked is to simply
have have it not be connected to the
internet so people need to physically
steal it right so we keep most of the of
our customers Bitcoin in offline servers
that are inside vault those walls are
deep underground in Bunker's our main
money's in Switzerland the reason to do
that is so if you want to steal those
because you actually need to break into
a bunker and a couple of other bankers
in different parts of the world at the
same time what do you see for the next
five years for Bitcoin and for example
we haven't yet seen the first currency
crisis of the Bitcoin era and it will be
interesting to see that you know and
there are candidate in Argentina
Venezuela and many other places when
this casares thank you very much for
talking to thank you for having me for
reason TV I'm Zack white male